all right it's finally here gpt4 has
been released and the amount of gbt in
this one is truly mind blowing it's
almost four as you can see in this
graphic so thanks to the Discord members
for this meme we're gonna get into gpt4
into their release into their technical
report or is it a paper or is it a
research report one doesn't know
um we're gonna get into what openai
released what gpt4 can do and the
controversial methods of the release
namely that they say absolutely nothing
about the model so let me warn you right
now if you expected here for me to make
a video like I usually do where I
discuss you know how big the model is
how they trained it what the the tricks
they used were and so on you know stuff
that's usually coming out of a research
lab you're gonna find none of that here
this is 98 page ages of them saying we
trained a model on data and it's good
and it's safe and they spend a lot of
time ensuring you that it is really
really safe and safe not in a way like
they previously did like oh it's safe
for Humanity or safe against biases and
things like this but much more safe in
terms of you can build this into a
product and you don't have to worry too
much that it's going to just whack out
and insult your customers so we now see
open AI to fully go away from anything
resembling a research organization to a
product organization this is a product
you may use it it probably is quite good
for some applications
um but yeah we have to we have to
contend with the fact that the big
research Labs now are going to be more
product oriented I strongly believe that
as a research Community we should not
accept this
um we we should be shaming open AI for
this and this is yeah it's not research
um you're now you're now a software shop
that's fine with me right but then don't
claim don't claim openness all right so
this is called a technical report they
have released uh two other or multiple
other things beside this technical
report let's see here they have also
released a product page this is a it's a
printout of the product this is a
website where it's product they have
videos of people looking at iPads and
going like oh
um and comparison to chat GPT and they
claim dpt4 is a lot better than chat GPT
uh they also have released a website
that's a research website they have two
websites one is called Product such
slash products slash gpt4 and one is
slash research slash gpt4 and the
research website is probably the one
that most people have seen or or are
seeing
um so this one is essentially a short
condensed form of the technical rep
report they're saying we've created gpt4
the latest milestone in openai's effort
in scaling up deep learning it's a large
multi-modal model so multimodal saying
they accept image and text inputs
emitting text outputs so in my mind this
is a little bit of a I want to say
disappointment and of course there there
was no other chance for gpt4 than to
disappoint people because expectations
have been huge right but people have
been speculating about can this do video
can this maybe also emit images and
things like this no it can take text and
it can take images as inputs and it can
output text so anything that you're used
to from the open AI text apis is still
possible but now also you're able to
provide an image yesterday or this
morning depending where you are Greg
Brockman did a live stream for
developers where he showed that he could
draw a little picture of a website like
he he drew and he essentially said okay
here is a website sketch here is a
button so here is a joke and then is a
button like reveal reveal the punch line
and he just sketched the website like
this really rude uh sorry really roughly
and he input the picture into gpt4 and
then gpt4 output the code to make the
website including functional buttons and
all that's pretty cool and that's now
possible you can take a picture of
something in the paper they also have
various reports of the model reasoning
over infographics and things like this
like you just screenshot something input
it there and ask the model about it so
that's that's pretty cool
um the other thing they did and what
surprised most people is they they uh
evaluated gpt4 on human tests so no
longer or in addition to academic
benchmarks now these models are more and
more tested on on human tests and you
can see here there are I don't know like
chemistry tests and and algebra tests
and things like this one that surprised
a lot of people or multiple ones that
surprised a lot of people for example
the the LSAT right here now the this
number
the numbers you see right here are the
percentile of the model so the 88th
percentile essentially means If This
Were a human uh how would it rank among
100 other humans so in this case uh gpt4
would be an 80 88 in 100 humans
um there is specifically one let me find
that there is a bar exam
so can I find it is it not here
is it not here
okay
well
it passes a simulated bar exam with a
score around the top 10 percent of test
takers in contrast GPT 3.5 That's the
older model score was around the bottom
10 so this is a bar like the test for
lawyers and it passes that better than
90 of humans so people have been saying
a lot of of things like ooh ringing the
alarm bells and so on and yes obviously
these language models are going to be
very very good in in terms of you know
wherever humans have to recant knowledge
and write it down in a verbose and
elaborate way those things are really
nice for these models but you have to be
you have to pay a bit of attention in in
terms of these human tests right these
models they're not humans and the tests
are specifically designed for humans
like the the tests look at where do
humans differ amongst each other and
then they specifically test for that
Dimension now that Dimension may be
something that the models that we train
are particularly good at or particularly
not good at
um but it doesn't necessarily say
anything about how they eventually
compared to a human when it comes to the
actual job so for example if you want to
be a lawyer you also have to interact
with clients you have to write emails
and schedule appointments now a model
may be able to do that you but you also
have to understand your clients a little
bit you have to talk to them you have to
make a connection you have to reason
about you know what to do next not only
in a legal sense but in the real world
every now and then you may have to climb
a set of stairs or an escalator
um you know so there are there are tons
and tons of things that humans have to
do that are really important for a job
my examples might be really bad right
now but I hope you understand what I
mean these tests only test where humans
differ from each other right and
evaluating the models on them is is nice
is good tells us about something about
progress but cannot really really get to
the heart of is this AGI is this you
know are our lawyers our lawyers going
to be unemployed in the future and so on
it's very much like if you were to let
um computers do a calculation like Brute
Force calculation test
um that you know you may be doing in in
lower grades of school your
multiplication tables and then you go
like and get the computer out and the
computer destroys the kids and you're
you're saying well
um that doesn't mean they're going to be
mathematicians uh or even or even good
you know quick calculators for that
matter
um yeah I hope I've made myself clear
you have to pay a bit of attention when
you apply machines to benchmarks that
are made for humans and which are
targeted at specifically
specifically seeing where humans differ
that being said gpt4 here
with and no no vision and with vision as
I said a variant of gpt4 can include
pictures does outperform GPT 3.5 the
older models um almost everywhere or
everywhere as far as I can see so you
can see the percentile here in blue that
is the percentile that the older models
of openai achieved and then various
times when the newer models really
outperform the older models
as I said the paper and also the website
go into detail on uh that first of all
the models are better now than the older
models but also giving a few examples
like this here so this is an example for
a visual input saying what's funny about
this image describe it panel by panel
and then gpt4 goes through and goes
panel by panel and explains the humor in
this image comes from the absurdity of
plugging a large outdated VGA connector
into a small modern smartphone charging
port so these are the types of things
you can do the technical report has some
more as I said reasoning about
infographics and things like this that
they have a few more examples about
mathy things and then
the paper the technical report sorry
goes along into
um what exactly is the limitation and
also how they made sure that the model
is really really safe so they spend a
lot of time on risks mitigating risks
they have a variant called early gpt4
and I'm assuming that's just a
pre-trained model and then final gpt4 is
sort of the the nerfed model the safety
aware model and I can't tell but I'm
sorry for the the printing here I can't
help but if you look at these examples I
can't help but very often think I would
have really loved talking to the earlier
model
um rather than the final model but you
know you can't have everything
the training
process here is is there there's really
nothing they essentially say we trained
to predict the next word in a document
and it was trained using publicly
available data such as internet data as
well as data we've licensed so it's
essentially saying data right
um
and then they they say so when prompted
with a question the base model can
respond in a wide variety of ways that
might be far from the user's intent to
align it with the user's intent within
guardrails we fine-tune the Model
Behavior using reinforcement learning
with human feedback this is a rather
recent development
um for in the last few years that you
take this these human inputs human
demonstrations of how you would like the
model to act and then apply it to a
pre-trained language model so that
essentially means the language model is
just trying to predict the next words in
a piece of text and with the
reinforcement learning you're really
getting it into a mode of of being
helpful and being assisting you in doing
some things specifically the open AI
models at least what they've shown in
the developer live stream they always
have they have two things they have what
they call a system parameter and then
they have the prompt
so this in the system parameter and
we've already seen that a little bit in
in chat GPT apis and so on the system
parameter you can tell the model how you
would like it to act for example you are
a programming
programming tutor
okay so you can tell it you're a
programming tutor and then in the prompt
you say something like I don't know help
me
debug some code right and the model will
respect this thing right here and use it
as a context to fulfill the prompter to
continue the prompt so using this system
parameter you have a lot of freedom
um to say to to specify how the model
should act so you're going to see the
system parameter in the apis if you use
them or in the playground once they make
that available
what I found interesting and this is
about the only actually informative
thing one can read from these papers and
reports and anything they've released is
this note that the model's capabilities
seem to come primarily from the
pre-training process the rlhf does not
improve exam performance without active
effort it actually degrades it
but steering the model comes from the
steering the model comes from the post
training process the base model requires
prompt engineering to even know what it
should answer that it should answer the
questions
so I've been I've been I think
commenting on this in previous videos
the human reinforcement learning really
is just getting the model into the mood
of helping you into the into the into
the mindset of being a Helper and an
assistant and the capabilities come from
the pre-training there are a lot of
people that try to to get these models
to learn new skills using this human
feedback data and that's really not the
point of it and I think they're making
this quite clear right here that the
human feedback it doesn't really help
get the model getting the model to be
better at stuff it just makes it such
that you don't have to do extensive
prompt engineering and waste context
tokens to get to do things so that's
pretty interesting they also spend quite
a big deal of time on the scaling laws
um
and yeah so maybe first I want to show
you in the technical report right here
in the technical report by the way they
can't really agree what they call this
so on a website that says read paper on
Twitter open AI people say read our
technical paper read our research paper
read our technical report I guess they
want to call it a paper but then also
not because they know this is nothing
like a paper this is one long ad like
this is this is at most like a white
paper you'd find from a company they
here in the scope and limitations of the
technical report they say
um given both the competitive landscape
and the safety implications of
large-scale models like gpt4 this report
contains no further details about the
architecture including model size
Hardware training compute data set
construction training method or similar
so nothing you're getting nothing out of
them any sort of semblance of research
is gone right here and don't give me
don't give me stupid safety implications
right they're saying it correctly here
competitive landscape they're saying
that first and I welcome openai for
finally coming out and just saying we
want to keep this to ourselves we want
to sell it to you and we're not even
gonna tell you what we learned about
these models
um my guess would be that they've used a
bunch of recent advances in the fields
like um like like like flash attention
like maybe self-instruct a little bit um
um
my guess would be that they've done that
including the recognitions of recent
projects on how effectively to trade off
data compute and model size and they
just you know put proprietary data into
this and tuned it to their to their
liking and from that they got a good
model and now they don't want you to
replicate it so the danger for open AI
would be it's I guess I guess you could
compare it to to other big research
projects maybe pharmaceutical companies
so they they invested a lot of money and
effort now into getting a good model but
if they would tell you how to do it if
they would tell you what they learned
you could probably reproduce it with
still a lot of money but not that much
money like they spent
um so they just don't want that they
want their competitive Advantage they
want to sell this
yes which is again fine but don't claim
your research right don't claim you're
you're or open or democratizing
everything or sharing or that you are
for the benefit of humanity because the
benefit of humanity would be for the
rest of the research Community to learn
these things and to be able to push the
research further in in a safe way okay
my guess would be that the model isn't
actually very big
um my guess would be that the model
isn't like a trillion parameters big
like people estimated that the models
just go larger and larger my guess would
be that they just trained for longer uh
because in recent paper that seems to be
the most first of all that seems to have
been the most effective in getting the
models to to become better and also if
you make a bigger model then at
inference time
um
it costs you more to provide that
service but if you make the same size
model but just train it for longer then
at inference time like we saw in the
Llama papers uh that will only cost you
you know the same amount for for the
model by the way the only actual numbers
they give in any of these are the prices
for their apis so that should tell you
something
um yeah so my guess would be this model
isn't actually that large it's just been
trained for longer and in you know with
with proprietary data and that's where
they get the quality from so yeah that's
just my guess also other models they
other numbers they give is when they
discuss these scaling laws
um what's impressive I would say is that
they can so these are let's say older
models from them or other people they
don't really say but the guess is that
it's older models from from them
and they say from this we could
accurately predict what the performance
of gpt4 will be by simply curve fitting
here and extrapolating this
of course means that you have more
security that your investment into
training such a big model will pay off
because you can you can sort of Follow
The Curve right here and determine where
you'll end up so you can make a better
guess now here they say compute but
compute is only in fraction so not even
they don't even tell you how much
compute they used they simply say this
is one one gpt4 and then this is you
know 100 times less this is 10 000 times
less and so on
uh this is next word prediction in a
code base and this model here is a
hundred thousand or ten thousand times
less compute sorry and they have other
graphs where they have a prediction on
coding problems where they have this a
thousand times less compute so the best
guesses are that gpt4 uses something
between
100 1000 or 10 000 I know these are Big
ranges but I would guess something like
1 000 times more compute than maybe went
into GPT three
or 100 times more compute it's not
really clear but it must be in that sort
of General range so from that we can
guess about what they did as I said I
also don't believe the model is
necessarily that much larger but just
trained for longer
the this is also very interesting
um open AI I believe it was open AI who
made this inverse scaling price the
inverse scaling price asked the
community for contributions of data sets
where the bigger the models get the
worse they get and this inverse scaling
price
um had a contribution called hindsight
neglect and it it seemed like that was
on Trend but gpt4 reverses that Trend
hindsight neglect specifically asked the
models it made a bet it's like you know
you
John John can take a bet
um John can lose 900 with 90 or with
five percent chance and Jones can win
five dollars with 95 chance
um so it's a bet where the expected
value favors one answer but then the the
text says John took the John took the
correct answer for example but lost
right so they took the correct expected
value but lost and then it asks a model
was John's decision correct and if the
model says yes it is assumed that the
model understands that even though John
lost they did the correct thing
according to expected value that if the
model says no then it's assumed to be
wrong it to me that does depend on your
interpretation of determinism like
clearly if Jon lost it was the wrong
decision in some way even though the
expected value was
um was positive if you're a determinist
never mind we're getting into philosophy
right here
so the this is It's the technical report
is very much the same as the website but
more extensive
um what's also funny is that they say
chat uh sorry not chat GPT GPT 4 was
used to write the technical report a
little bit or to do I think to do a lot
Tech formatting
okay so many things to talk about here
please cite this work as open AI 2023
right this is branding this is where
we're we're off off on on uh like I'm
usually not a fan of papers with many
many many many many many many many many
many many many authors
but I'm more a fan of that than we're
now supposed to cite open AI
um pure branding we're like pure
branding yes
[Music]
at some point they say here gpt4 was
used to help with wording formatting and
styling throughout this work and I've
discovered it's on page we
page somewhere down I discovered
a mistake of gpt4 oh this one is also
funny
what's the unusual thing about this
image the unusual thing about this image
is that a man is ironing clothes on an
ironing board attached to the roof of a
moving taxi I I don't see why why that's
unusual that seems perfectly perfectly
fine in the USA
um
yeah so this is a visual input example
below is part of the instruct GPT paper
could you read and summarize it for me
so it seems to be able to do OCR maybe a
bit out of the box although it is
unclear with many of these things how
much training data contamination they
had
um
they say
they claim the knowledge cut of his 2001
oh it explains this meme
and it it it it it knows what but
unironically uh means they say the
knowledge cutoff is 2001.
but but they say mostly so no one knows
what that means literally no one knows
what that means okay no one knows what
mostly means clearly the model knows
more than
um clearly the model knows more than
that
and it's assumed and people have already
confirmed that that a lot of these eval
sets are also part of the training data
of gpt4
that the paper itself claims not as much
all right we want to find figure eight
figure eight is here
performance on truthful care what irony
um so this one right here I really want
to know which which of the authors you
know given that there's only one author
open AI
um is responsible for leaving a lot Tech
comment or a commit message
um inside of the inside of the figure uh
caption
so maybe gpt4 isn't as good as claimed
if it if it can't even do that
no um I'm I'm I'm joking um I would like
to see you know what that entails or who
who who is responsible for this
the last thing I want to talk about
right here is their release of open AI
evals so this is an actual open source
repository
um
and
right here
oh yeah anthropic is also releasing
cloud and Google is releasing an API for
uh Palm I believe and integrating it
into Google workspace so lots of
releases this week but open AI released
this evals
repository they're saying it's a
framework for evaluating open AI models
and an open source registry for
benchmarks
these are benchmarks for these language
models they say for a limited time we'll
be granting GPT for access to those who
contribute high quality evals
so this is I like this is
it's open sourcing something actually
um but it's just please like help us get
better so you contribute evil sets to
them and uh if you do a good job you get
access to their to their models oh thank
you open AI if you also have chat GPT
plus you get limited access to it and
Bing released a blog post saying that
even if you've used Bing anytime in the
last five weeks you've already
experienced an early version of this
powerful model so if you've you know the
demonstrations we've seen out of Bing
very likely they were using gpt4 behind
the behind the scenes with respect to
open source I I invite you to go to
YouTube and and watch the developer live
stream because at some point uh Greg
Brockman asks the model to write a poem
about open ai's release of gpt4 and the
poem includes something like all open
source and I just I laughed so hard uh
yeah yes
uh the irony and the the shot is
fantastic it's Greg Brockman smiling
saying like look what a cool poem and
the poem is is just uh completely wrong
maybe it's the model maybe it's the
model becoming conscious and and telling
us something
in any case uh that was my brief brief
dive into gpt4 I hope this was
sufficient for you the API right now is
um usable and there is a wait list for
the API where they let you sign up and
if they deem your heart pure they let
you access it however the vision access
isn't yet enabled they say you can make
text only requests to the gpt4 model
image inputs are still in limited Alpha
um
my question is a little bit what what oh
there is a read paper again
my question is a little bit
what prompted them no pun intended to
release it right now what why
because they they don't seem to be that
ready like the image inputs still aren't
here so it's just a bit of a better chat
GPT or a bit of a better GPT 3.5
um
was it the the German Microsoft exec
that already announced it or what
prompted them did they get a whiff of
Google releasing their API and anthropic
releasing their API there's so much
stuff going on right here uh which would
be very interesting to figure out but
we don't know in any case this was my as
I said my short overview over gpt4
um if you like stuff like this don't
hesitate to join our Discord we have
paper discussions every week every day
even sometimes about cool papers and
yeah uh if you get access if you have
chat GPT plus maybe you can try out the
new model they claim that it can follow
instructions a lot better
who knows
um but I would expect I would expect
honestly this this is as I said at the
beginning a bit
a bit disappointing right
um what we get is a model that is you
know better than chat GPT better than
GPT 3.5 but it's not sort of the
Revolutionary breakthrough
um in either a performance or
multi-modality that were speculated
about as I said there was almost no way
to fulfill that but I still believe in
in light of all of this this is a bit of
a disappointment on top of that the
giant disappointment of how they
released things my
um one of my most watched videos is
about gpt3 and I still remember that
paper next to being a very in-depth
evaluation
in-depth evaluation exploration much
more than this paper technical report is
it had also a lot of details around the
modalities around how they train the
model and so on and it led to you know
it led to the spur of a lot of
development a lot of Open Source
replications a Luther Ai and so on and
this right here it's just disappointing
on a lot of levels
nevertheless I believe this may be good
in order to build something against what
the world has to contend with a little
bit is
are we really happy to send sensitive
data let's say you're a business are you
really happy to send sensitive data to
open AI right
um they state in the paper right here
that they have in fact trained on
um real production data they state that
in the technical report somewhere that
they fine-tuned on real production data
on Twitter somewhere they say we don't
train on production data but I recall
somewhere in these reports I read that
so you know you're essentially relying
on open ai's word that they're not gonna
do that when they have clearly done it
in the past are you comfortable as a
business sending your stuff there are
you comfortable sending your clients
stuff there I think that is a question
that the business world will have to
answer in the next few years and it's
going to be interesting to see where
that goes and what that implies for sort
of the the landscape of data security
and privacy
all right that was it from me I hope you
have an absolutely fantastic day and
I'll see you around bye